من اجل تجنب الشعور بالارهاق المفرط
والحصول على تعافن جيد بعد العمل ينصح احد
المختصين النفسيين في جامعه ستوني بروكا
الامريكيه بعده طرق اولها القيام بانشطه
تساعد على الانفصال ذهنيا عن العمل مثل
ممارسه الهوايات او قضاء الوقت مع احبائك
ومقابله اصدقائك قراءه كتاب او حتى مشاهده
فيلم الانفصال عن العمل يعني ايضا عدم
التحقق من رسائل البريد الالكتروني الخاصه
بالعمل بعد انتهاء وقت الدوام ممارسه
تمارين تامل اليقظه الذهنيه والاسترخاء من
ثلاث الى خمس دقائق على الاقل ويفضل
ممارستها قبل النوم لمساعده العقل والجسم
في الحصول على نوم مريح طيب ماذا نفعل اذا
لم نستطع الالتزام بكل ما سبق لا تزال
هناك بعض الاستراتيجيات لتحسين الحاله
المزاجيه خلال اليوم التالي في العمل
التنفس بعمق مثلا وممارسه تمارين الاطاله
من وقت لاخر اخيرا التفاعل والتواصل مع
زملائك اث ناء فترات الراحه ويفضل
ان تتحرر
العمل ونحن سالنا الناس في مصر كيف تقضي
وقتك بعد ساعات العمل نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
بقعد لي ساعه ساعه ونص في الجيم وبعد كده
بروح بقى وبقعد مع ابني مع زوجتي
وبنتلمه ولو انا مثلا في اقدر ازور والدتي
بروح ازورها ما بقدرش يبقى بستنى يوم
الاجازه بتاعتي اتفرج موفي بيلعب بلاي
ستيشن بيحكي اصحابه بهدي شوي بهالموضوع
يعني بحب اكون مع عائلتي الصغيره
دي تعديل مزاجي خالص يعني بعد الغدا ممكن
انزل اتمشى شويه في النادي
بحب اتمشى في النجيله الخضار واليها ريحه
بتفوق ايه الموضوع نفسي مش اكتر من كده
ليه اهتمامات بالجوانب الزراعيه وطلعت كل
ما يدور في في مصر تحديدا في العالم
العربي لاي رياضه عشان يخرج من المود بتاع
الشغل دوت وما يبقاش فيه اي ضغوط عليه ولا
اي مشاكل تبقى ماثره عليه يعني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات